hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what's her name I'm John Humphrys I mean
John Bailey John Bailey is here with us
today epic voice guy himself hey you do
voices for some of the Avengers actors
that's true like one of them yeah at
some point we might hear some of those
appear in this video we're gonna do a
try not to laugh challenge if I know
John Bailey he likes to laugh he's gonna
have to try not to imma giggler have you
ever seen these unnecessary censorship
and no I have not I mix I haven't even
heard of them before
well you'll pick up on the concept
really fat hurt fans if I don't make it
very long on the nut laughing part well
just reset it's not a real competition
there's no money at the end of this
alright so Ninja Panda made this video
try not to laugh end game unnecessary he
did exactly what he said he was gonna do
Sana's 15 percent of all living
creatures no he wasn't my face with no
whales
[Music]
you [ __ ] we need what are you gonna stop
no I want to do it right we're gonna
need to really be bigger what's new with
new monster hey it's floor again you
know the god of thunder listen buddy if
you don't log off this game immediately
I'm gonna fly over your house come down
to that basement you're hiding in rip
off your then shove them up your butt
let's go cried you far be a look thank
you for thank you for got a job to do
is that what you're calling this
all these people is gonna bring your
family back ask you James
no no she stuck her hand inside of this
one time and and then stopped itself
inside her and became very very
[Music]
[Laughter]
successful with this man extract of
reality stone and get gone let me split
particularly only one but what do you
think we're doing here so is it too much
to ask do you brush the Lu been pretty
pants and when she's not looking
sucky and help me get my family back one
is that low-key 14th floor I'm not
looking
and I don't want to put a decent strange
panels so much safe for the Avengers you
know you want to have loved here with
the stone without his it's not a
coincidence
no don't you get out decent what do you
think I'm going to do it I'm trying
did you see what happens in the future
what he does it can't be undone or
that's at least what the red floating
guy had to say maybe you want to go okay
go grab your hammer and you go yeah
in the future what happens to you and me
what to do - stubborn annoying
enjoy very very much just so you know
this is my ship still your first
unnecessary censorship I mean I've seen
videos like this before so brilliant
like I wasn't sure what to expect it to
the very first whatever in Japan did
this guy does a girl go goes through
like the whole movie it just has to pay
attention to every lie to be like if we
changed that one with a suddenly made
this this movie of end game that sounds
like Thanos is a guy who sexually
assaults people by assaulting each other
but it's funny what the power you can do
with just changing one thing one thing
to a not even a word it's beep it in
your imagination yeah unfortunately your
imagination totally takes over and then
it's our to keep a straight face
this seems like this would be something
like super easy to do I was gonna be
easy not to like all right whatever
well it's so funny when you have certain
moments that actually seem like rather
than just because it's easily could've
just been a cut like a cop
elation of a bunch of different lines
but when they make a scene out of it
that completely changes the whole like
nebulae feel like they're talking about
that is so funny
we're like what strange strange insects
with that understand the rock kind of
confused a lot of beefs in that from the
town watching this this video only has
25,000 views I think it should they
should be viral at this point I think
you're I'm sorry about that right there
[Laughter]
probably gonna do something innocent or
Blue's Clues it's it's pretty and it's
pretty impressive I would want to
editing nude Wow I would want to see
this version of patreon enough like does
your patreon offer a full-length movie
or you go through the entire film and
you and you do this because then I would
definitely be pledging to your patreon
this was hilarious guys if you haven't
subscribed to the ninja Panda channel
yet make sure to do that right away has
he or she musher has a budget they
gender-neutral has a whole bunch of
these unnecessary natural uncertain
interships unnecessary censorship you
can subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell you can
check out john bailey epic voice guy
all of them cross all pacific tik-tok
and it's the epic boys guys the only one
i know that's a thing that's actually
kind of a lot of fun on take that people
are lost actually doing things have won
over
half a million years I'll take that Wow
Bailey oh no you're becoming famous John
Bailey here's I'm gonna ask you to do
and one of the Avengers voices like I'm
laughing for Thor to say why Avengers
voices we have Rosa para she is one of
our top reward tier patron she has her
own blog on Instagram and Twitter called
roses roses reviews okey-dokey
roses reviews got it all so obsessed
with John Humphrey if it's a female
patron what are you getting so obsessive
joy that girls love you John yeah it's
the garlic it's a wonderful mother
shatter out for us John hello there
welcome Rosa Parra you are incredible
earthling to support these these poor
fellows and I know I know John Humphrey
has wonderful illustrious hair but I to
the Lord of thunder
well a little sparkles god of thunder
III do have a lose here you should like
me better and I you know God and stuff
like house God whatever and kill thanos
shout out roses reviews on Instagram and
Twitter if you need things reviewed you
got a good a razor to pee but they're so
good make sure you wear your brown pants
you'll thank me later
there'll bring some air freshener you're
gonna need it they're that good drink
aviation gin because I own the company
we only got you for five more minutes
we're cutting this